hello father's day is around the corner
and there are so many great spots to
celebrate around town we have lifestyle
expert amy costan here to give us the
father's day in the valley rundown
and i have to say two keys to dad's
heart
food
and golf
at least to my dad's right yeah right
right i know i know but you know some of
these ideas incorporate fun for everyone
right right like so the first one at the
house of blues have you done the gospel
brunch there i have not but i have heard
about it it's
a staple in the community this is back
as of april
and it is fun for the whole family so
all ages it's a good time miss patty
pennington is a host you get to eat good
food you get to like be lifted by the
spirit i'm telling you it is a win-win
for everyone okay i love that i love
that and of course keeping it simple
food yes you can't go wrong with just a
steak dinner yes yes absolutely so at
locale
italian kitchen and mountains edge they
have the best deal on tomahawk steak so
check this out normally it's tomahawk
tuesday okay but they're doing this for
sunday father's day for specifically 129
for two people you get the tomahawk
steak you get the appetizer of your
choice you get dessert and sides it's
the whole thing for 129 bucks do you
guys see that i just want to
oh so yeah i'm ready to eat it so good
and after all the food we'll work it out
a little bit i mean top golf though you
can't miss this one
gift certificate if you buy a 75 gift
certificate you get a 20 bonus so that's
pretty awesome yeah but if you don't
want to plan ahead they open early they
open at 9 00 a.m okay that day so you
can get in there and have a good time
with yourself and they've got a little
air conditioner misters going fine it's
really fun so so fun i love top coat it
really doesn't get old too it doesn't
get old 10 million times but it can be
very frustrating as well if you're like
me
absolutely
and then gentlemen's tonic have you been
to the rampart over at jw
oh my gosh j.w marriott has redone their
entire spa okay they have gentlemen's
tonight
we're seeing photos of it right now oh
my gosh because everyone always thinks
you know self-care is for mom and the
ladies but dads deserve too dads need it
they need it and this way they get to
get all clean smelling good
you get a little product in there and
it's just a good time for him absolutely
absolutely so just in general you know
would you say las vegas is a dad's town
it's a father's day town yes yes and i
actually have one more idea for you
let's do it the comedy seller
of course yes yes so for 22 dollars a
person you get to sit down have a great
show
laugh and you do that by going online cc
vegas is the code 22 later you're in
there laughing with dad i love that and
that's a good laugh some good food a
good game of round of golf couple rounds
all around
music gospel brunch a little spiritual
spirit steak
you've got everything you need right
here in las vegas for dad to celebrate
that and where can people get more
information about you and your lifestyle
expert oh my goodness i would say
expertise i should say go to your
website and it will be all right there